born this morning at 7 43 weighing a
healthy seven pounds and four ounces
baby Huckleberry is one of the nhs's
youngest patients
he's doing very well we're only five
hours I think in doing his life so um no
very happy and it's my third boy here so
we've been very grateful to the NHS but
as new life is brought into the world
how are you feeling tired of this white
grannies the Urgent work to save lives
goes on
Graham Hart is receiving the most modern
care for his stage four liver and colon
cancer but his treatment is being
carried out in a building that opened in
1839 and it shows the fact is that then
some of these Builders are just not fit
for purpose as we can see here we go it
rained last night as you will remember
and unfortunately also rained in here so
patient care continues we'll get on
without the staff here of brilliant the
fact that we used to deal with this
tells you something about the challenges
that we face on a day-to-day basis and
it's in conditions like this that the
NHS must work to bring down record
waiting lists at a time when demand for
services continues to grow
and this pressure was acknowledged in
London where NHS staff passed and
present were celebrated at a special
ceremony at Westminster Abbey the health
services chief executive Amanda
Pritchard paid tribute to her staff but
although We Gather in this in this great
place
don't
nor do we ignore the challenges we have
faced and particularly those we face
today
but it is in our continuous and
Collective pursuit of doing our very
best for patients and these patients
continue deriving at hospitals across
the country I am always a bit blown away
when I go back into Peds and actually
have a look at that and see how it's
changed and everything Steve McManus
started as a nurse he now runs the Royal
Berkshire NHS trust he welcomes a new
15-year Workforce plan to boost the
number of health staff but says they
need the infrastructure to do their jobs
properly we also need a longer term
plan like the NHS Workforce plan that
starts to address the sort of physical
environment the technological
environment the kit that we need to
deliver Modern Health and Care Services
the government says it will eventually
deliver thousands of extra doctors
nurses and other Healthcare
professionals but not yet
the workforce plan is long term the
benefits won't be felt for years to come
in Precious for the NHS are here and now
this emergency department recorded its
busiest everyday just a few weeks ago
we're in summer there are pressures all
year round
hello hi I'm just here to present this
certificate to Baby Huckleberry because
he was born on the same day the NHS
turned 75. there is no denying the NHS
it's history but unless it gets the
urgent help it needs there is no
certainty it will be here for
Huckleberry in the future yeah Ashish
Joshi Sky News at the Royal Berkshire
Hospital in Reading